j'ai plaqué mon chêne comme un saligo
mon copain le chîne mon
altterriigo on était du même bois un peu
rustique un peu brute dont on fait
n'importe quoi sauf naturellement les
flûes j'ai maintenant des freines des
arbres de Judée tous de bonnes graines
de haute futée mais toi tu manques à
l'appel ma vieille branche de campagne
mon solabre de Noël mon de Cocagne
auprès de mon arbre je vivais heureux
j'aurais jamais dû m'éloigner de mon
arbre auprès de mon arbre je vivais
heureux j'aurais jamais dû le quitter
les yeux je suis un pauvre type j'auraai
plus de joie j'ai jeté ma pipe ma
vieille pipe en bois qui avait fumé sans
se fâcher sans jamais me brûler la Lipe
le tabac de la vache ragé dans sa bonne
vieille tête de pipe j'ai les pipes
d'écumes horné de fleuron de ces pipes
qu' fume en levant le front mais je
retrouverai plus ma foi dans mon cœur ni
sur ma Lipe le goût de ma vieille pipe
en bois sacré nom d'une pipe auprès de
mon arbre je vivais heureux j'aurais
jamais dû m'éloigné de mon arbre auprès
de mon arbre je vivais heureux
j'aurais jamais dû le quitter les yeux
le surnom d'infemme me va comme un Gan
là avec ma femme j'ai foutu le camp
parce que depuis tant d'années c'était
pas une sinineécure de lui voir tout le
temps le nez au milieu de la figure je
bas la campagne pour dénicher là
nouvelle compagne valan cellel qui bien
sûr laissait beaucoup trop de pierres
dans les lentilles mais se pendait à mon
cou quand je perdais mes billes auprès
de mon arbre je vivais heureux j'aurais
jamais dû m'éloigner de mon arbre auprès
jamais dû le quitter les
yeux